hey guys I have some bad news basically
I'm not going to be able to make videos
for a while either until halfway through
this year or even until December you see
video making takes a crazy amount of
time which I had for the last half year
because I took a break from studying but
now not only am i back at university I'm
doing an intensive one-year course with
classes and my own research and I don't
have much spare time it's been going for
a month already and it's a huge amount
of work but I love it the [ __ ] thing is
I love making these videos too and I'm
really upset that I won't be able to for
a while the consolation for me is that
I'm learning so much and I can't wait to
make videos about all of it my research
is in the field of quantum computers and
it's on the coolest topic it's about
figuring out what makes quantum
computers more powerful than classical
computers which is very controversial
I'm also taking a bunch of awesome
subjects like general activity and
relativistic quantum mechanics plus I
have all these other interests like
maths and biology that I also want to
make videos about and after this year
I'll have the time I'm taking at least
another year off University after this
one before doing a PhD and I'm going to
dedicate that time to making this
channel much better that's where I need
your help so many of you guys have
watched my videos and left super kind
comments but I don't want any of that
now be ruthless and tell me where I can
improve and I know there's tons to
improve should I make my videos longer
or shorter or change the timing should I
make some follow-up reading and
questions should I acquire a better
sense of humor could I get a totally
different set up altogether I don't know
but I trust that each one of you has
some very valuable ideas leave them as
comments for me if you agree with
someone else's suggestions then like
their comment and if you disagree with
them it would be awesome if you could
explain why but I guess it's time for
goodbye now thank you though thank you
for watching my videos and thank you to
anyone who comment
and will comment and thank you for all
the thought-provoking questions you guys
kept me company and kept me motivated
when a lot of people didn't understand
what I was doing with my time I will be
back and with your help
better